Narrator:
On Thursday, Feb. 16th, the Princeton University
Concert series presents violin virtuoso Julia
Narrator:
Fischer making her Princeton debut with pianist
Milana Chernyavska. The concert will take
Narrator:
place at Richardson Auditorium in Alexander Hall.
Edward Skolnick:
When I found out that Julia Fischer was coming
to Princeton and was going to be playing in
Edward Skolnick:
Richardson Auditorium, I just honestly couldn't believe it.
When she comes to the U.S., usually she's
playing in venues like Carnegie Hall, and
Edward Skolnick:
the idea that she would be coming to Princeton
and doing a recital here is just beyond comprehension
Edward Skolnick:
for me.
I think what makes her performances so special
is the intensity that she brings to the music.
Edward Skolnick:
You could call it a stage presence but it
is so, so much more than that. It's just an
Edward Skolnick:
entire way of commanding an audience, the
piece, the violin, the whole package.
[music]
Edward Skolnick:
For really anyone who is or is not a fan of classical music, I can guarantee that this
is going to be an astounding performance.
The bar is certainly very high for this concert.
Edward Skolnick:
This season of concerts has been unlike anything
I have ever seen at Princeton University Concerts,
Edward Skolnick:
but I fully expect Julia Fischer to blow everybody's
socks off. She never disappoints.
[music]